foreign
let's go to Lynn in Dallas Texas hey
Lynn what's up
hi can you hear me all right I can how
are you
I'm doing good how are you having the
time of my life literally the best day
ever that's probably a stretch yeah but
we're trying right what's up yes I'm a
little nervous here okay so have you've
heard this show right I know I know I
know
we're all it's different though we're
clearly making this up as I go so you're
you're good
okay
um it's kind of a lot so I have like my
little points that I kind of outlined so
I'm just going to go with it very good
read them all let's do it okay
so I basically I grew up in like a
Christian home uh very spiritual
background uh parents or pastors things
like that and so they so you're clearly
traumatized uh yeah nope okay go on yeah
okay and so
um
so basically
um
I wasn't like allowed to have a
boyfriend you know things like that
growing up you know kind of stay away
from everything like that so five years
ago
um I'm out on my own working all that
fun stuff and
I was sexually assaulted by a co-worker
really
yeah okay okay so hold on let's just
stop for a second
you are a preacher's kid
and you are masterful
at
having an experience and then quickly
and dutifully brushing it off the table
so it doesn't ruin anybody else's time
and that ends right now
cool
yeah growing up with two parents that
are pastors even if they're wonderful
people doing their best is hard the part
of my life story that I don't tell very
often is that my dad was a homicide
detective for half my life and then he
quit literally over a weekend and became
a pastor
and my life changed
it's hard
and my dad was pretty good at the being
very transparent with me and being open
with me it was still hard right so
um
you grew up in a hard situation and your
parents intentionally
um for what for whatever host of reasons
um
didn't allow you to experience certain
types of relationships
and that's hard right
and then a co-worker somebody that
should be safe safe safe
takes everything from you
yeah
how many times have you said that out
loud
this would
I thought
I I wrote it down a lot and so I didn't
think I was
I'm gonna get a little choked up with
that part when I actually said it grief
Demands a witness
and I'll sit here with you
um
so that was
five years ago okay
um
it makes it a little more rough because
the person that did that was actually
aware that I was saving myself for
marriage and that I hadn't had a
boyfriend and all of that he actually
knew that
um and at the time I was also interning
at a church and so so you take Section
oh hold on so you take sexual assault
and on top of it
you're taking some very clear moral
boundaries that you've drawn for
yourself some boundaries you'd placed on
yourself
in a context and he knowingly
smashed those
and then you throw on top of that how
notoriously awful churches are at
responding to these sorts of things and
that's where you work and so you had to
you were probably the problem if you
said anything so you probably said
nothing
yeah and I don't blame you for that
because you didn't have a context for
that you didn't have parents you could
go to you didn't have friends you could
go to you didn't have co-workers you
could go to and now you can't go to your
church right so you've been your body
has frozen in time
that's why five years later you can say
this out loud for the second time and it
it's like oh is that the light is that
it starts coming out right away right
and you're so good you're so good you
can stamp that stuff out real quick
Fair yeah yes yeah okay I apologize I
keep interrupting you and that's that's
it you're good that's a rude thing to be
for me to be doing right now the last
thing you need is for some idiot to take
away your autonomy yet again so go ahead
and continue I'll do my best
interrupting you
yeah I I didn't even tell my church for
a year after it actually happened but
since I was there
um I I didn't tell them so I was still
interning at the church and then I kind
of felt like I was playing a role where
people are coming to me and like help
asking for advice for things and then
I've got all this going on on the side
um so when I did tell them about it like
a year later
they
overstepped quite a bit and just like
shoved all sorts of therapy down my
throat and tears resources and so this
is what you need to do and they were
telling everyone so people I didn't even
know were approaching me and telling me
their stories
and so I ultimately left that church
good they don't deserve you they don't
deserve you
can't have that that was a lot so
um I I did go to some of the therapy to
spell after that happened
um
and
I felt like
I was making progress now I'm starting
to question that
I'm telling the story
um but I I feel like I've made some good
progress over the last four years
um as a result of that
which is kind of good information to
know the way that I kind of coped with
that situation was by starting to drink
I started drinking pretty heavily I did
start sleeping around a little bit
um and so I did that for about a year
okay so can I pause you can I can I have
your permission to cut you off for a
second yes okay
um super super common response you're
not crazy
a very common response to having
somebody steal your sexuality from you
is an attempt to reclaim ownership of it
yeah does that make sense by entering
into a whole bunch of other sexual
relationships so that I I am in control
and I will exert it and it's often
followed by feeling really bad about
yourself and shameful and so the way
we're gonna overcome feeling bad about
ourselves is we're going to reclaim it
even more
and sometimes those experiences escalate
um or they accelerate and they uh get
riskier right but I'm I'm in control
right so that's super common and alcohol
literally the problem with alcohol is it
works until it kills you yeah yeah
it does shut the it shuts everything off
it does and so I want you to hear me say
you're not crazy you're not a terrible
human being okay
yeah
okay all right back in
play yeah so
um I I stopped that stop stop sleeping
around
um cut back a lot of the drinking got
a new therapist new psychiatrist so I've
really been working on myself really
trying to kind of heal and recover from
that very cool so
um
now
I'm getting to the point
where I want to start dating want to
start finding someone
and I've kind of set my own new kind of
boundaries and standards and what I
would like to happen all right hold on I
got to cut you off again
Lynn
you're not gonna kind of maybe set me no
you're freaking Lynn from Dallas
here's my boundaries this is the way I'm
Gonna Roll cause I'm Lynn from Dallas
and I don't give a crap what you think
or what you say none zero
until we have enough of a relationship
that I give you access to my heart which
by the way is mine to give out not my
parents not my crappy church that failed
me not the people who have been asking
for my advice and wisdom for all these
years I decide
and then when you give access to
somebody then you care
right then they have permission my wife
has permission to hurt me which means
she also has permission to love me
deeply
okay and those things work in tandem but
right now no you're like I'm kind of
thinking about some boundaries no Lynn
you're all in you're a gangster dude
nobody's messing with Lynn right right
yes yes good okay play
Okay so the boundaries that I have set
are that when I find the right person I
don't want to have sex until we're
married right I think that that's very
honoring to God and I want our
relationship to start out in that way
can I ask you this
does it honor you
it's us okay
you have to be a part of the honoring
equation
you can't leave yourself out okay you've
left yourself out your whole life
or let me put it this way everyone left
you out
and nobody bothered to tell you that you
were worth honoring too
and so
if your relationship and your to God and
your faith and your psychology work and
all of this has led you to a place where
this is what I want for me
then you owe nobody any explanation for
that none zero
whatever it may be
okay
yeah you're worth being honored
and you get to decide what that honoring
looks like
cool
yeah I hate that nobody's ever told you
that
yeah you should have got that that
your parents aren't here to defend
themselves so I'm gonna not talk about
them no all right go ahead
hopping into
uh when it comes to starting to to date
and having clear
expectations of who I'm interested in
someone like-minded shares the same
belief things like that
um the issue that I'm having is either
I'll find someone that
is also saving themselves and once I
tell them about my past history they'll
usually say sorry I'm looking for
someone that's you know waited and all
of that which is fair
or I run into the people that say they
have the same values and it's so cool
but then they'll also say well I think
we should move in together and we should
definitely have sex anyway and we're
going to get married so it's fine and
not what I want and so the question
which I think you sort of answered a
little bit already was if I should
adjust my boundaries to kind of be more
aligned with my options yes you should
absolutely compromise your values I
think you're set your boundaries too
high
You're Expecting too much of people and
you should water down what you feel and
what you think is right so that uh
somebody will like you
that sounds insane right it does yeah
don't do that
don't do that yeah
it's real real frustrating right now
because you've put in a ton of work to
heal
and you're lonely is all bloody hell
right
yeah and this is the part that gets left
out of the conversation sex is
connecting
it does make you feel less alone for a
season it has a back end to it right
that makes it
it has a downstream effect that makes
you lonelier over time right if you're
just if you're being used for sex you're
using other people for sex right and
that's not religious woo-woo that's out
of the scientific literature
but
it is connecting
and when you cut that off cold turkey
and you quit drinking suddenly you're
faced with this Stark real pain from a
sexual assault you're having to deal
with and stare down and walk through
parents who didn't show up for you
because they were too busy doing things
not of this Earth
right yeah and it's lonely
and so
you can get in line with millions and
millions and millions of other people
who have just settled
and just said and now and I'm not saying
like no bro she's got to be a perfect 10
and if she doesn't have abs and well
those idiots I'm not talking about that
I'm talking about settling on the things
that as we talked about earlier honor
you
and you get to choose those things
yeah right
yeah
what I would recommend is backing out of
the romance part of all of this
do you have a group of friends you just
go hang with
don't you don't
because you're probably not religious
enough for the Jesus Freaks and you're
probably too Faith oriented for people
that you think are just regular people
is that fair
you nailed it and
some of my best friends on the planet
are atheist
some of my and I'm a Christian guy for
those that some of my best friends in
the world have different political ideas
than me have lives that look very
different than mine
and that changed when I quit being an
arrogant idiot assuming that other
people were going to be certain ways
yeah
okay and so what you need is a healthy
dose of just good old-fashioned
friendship
which means you are going to have to
just go be weird
and hospitable and say I'm having a
holiday get together everybody come over
and bring whatever you got left in your
house
and I'm gonna Lynn I'm gonna give you
all the questions for humans let me give
you every one of them except for the
parents and kids ones and you're just
like we're just gonna ask talk we're
gonna hang out and play this stupid
questions thing that this podcaster gave
me and we're just gonna go on rabbit
holes and if you invite seven or eight
people three or four might come
yeah right and the other three or four
you were raised in a house where it's
your job to make sure everybody else was
okay you got to quit doing that because
it's an exhausting task that's not your
job
those three or four people are not gonna
come you know why because of things
they're going through not because of you
or it might be because of you because
you're weird who cares yeah because of
them they don't want to go cool I'm not
going to hang on to that I'm gonna
invite people to my house
and if only two show up cool we'll eat
whatever half casserole we got left and
whatever weird box of cereal you had
left and oh you got like a quarter
bottle of wine let's just mix them all
together and create ugh and we'll have
that and we're just gonna play games
or if you're trying not to drink cool
we're gonna have a Diet Coke Fest
whatever we're doing
and we're gonna get to know each other
and out of that group one or two people
will emerge as
we connected I like that dude I like her
she's pretty cool
what you really need practice at is
relationship
because you're running into these things
looking for Romance
without the skill set of how to be a
friend
how to be in somebody else's space does
that make sense
yes and so let's practice being in other
people's space and what's going to
emerge out of that is ugh some ooh
romance gross
and somebody's gonna show up with some
guy who's gonna bring it him over and
you're gonna be like hmm and he's gonna
be like hmm and then it's just going to
get gross and weird
right
yeah
and then you'll have had time to
practice relationship you'll have to
have time to practice telling the truth
and practice being vulnerable and
practice being intimate and open without
sex those are all skills they're not
moral issues or character flaws they're
just skills man and most of us don't
have those skills we have to learn them
is that cool
yeah you trust me
I do okay here's what we're looking for
fun laughter
like from your guts
being able to say yeah I was sexually
assaulted sucked
took five years of my life
it took a big part of my identity it
just stole it and I've had a lot of
healing
what about you
can you imagine being able to do that
not in a flippant way not in a lack of
compassion way but in a way that
my body doesn't react anymore on me
because I've been through the trauma
healing part of this thing and now I can
talk about it as a cautionary tale now I
can talk about it as a
um I am I am
really convicted about women having the
opportunity and the right to speak on
behalf of their own bodies you see what
I'm saying
yeah there's a powered strength that
comes from the other side of grieving
and healing
okay and you're worth all of that yeah
Fair
yeah yeah that's that's fair do not
compromise
the things that honor you
and since you're a person that shares my
same Faith trajectory don't compromise
on things that uh
you believe dishonor God
okay yeah
make choices in the present that future
Lynn is going to be really grateful that
you made even when they're hard
foreign
that's fair okay so before uh
um
you got 72 hours three days
is that three days yes I don't know how
math works
you got three days to set up an event at
your apartment or your house wherever
you live
cool
okay and I'll get all these things out
in the mail to you and I'm uh I want you
to use them I want you to have fun and
if you don't use the cards that's cool
man watch Die Hard the greatest
Christmas movie of all time uh like
watch old movies whatever it is
but let's get weird and let's be
hospitable let's go first let's invite
people over and we're going to start
making friends
and if they want to opt out cool and if
they just want to talk about politics
and covet well then that's probably not
this prize in the house for you
or we're gonna have hard conversations
whatever it is whatever it is
you're worth being in relationship with
you're worth being friends with
and yes you're worth romantic love and
it will come it will it will happen it
will happen it will happen
so my I'm blessed to have gotten to
speak with you and talk to you thank you
for being brave and being open please
apologize the last thing you needed was
some idiot interrupting you 45 times and
I apologize
you're so worth being loved
and it's on the way